connaissez-vous l'Hôpital des Nounours
la balle et patients sont des doudous et
les médecins des étudiants en santé un
parcours de soins pour de faux qui s'est
tenu récemment aux halles de tour avec
un objectif très sérieux aider les
enfants à dédramatiser l'hôpital
je te laisse l'enfiler
[Musique]
examen de santé complet
ces peluches passent voir tous les
praticiens car elles sont toutes bien
mal en point
[Musique]
il a très mal
il est dans le orange
il a un petit peu mal l'association
hôpital des nounours de Tours s'est
installé pendant deux jours au Halles le
but de l'opération soignait la peur de
la blouse blanche chez les enfants grâce
à des ateliers ludiques on crée un
parcours de sang pour le doudou et le
doudou va se faire soigner il vient à
l'hôpital et se faire soigner le but
c'est vraiment d'apporter une vision
assez rassurante de ce que c'est
l'hôpital la santé la maladie ce sont
des étudiants de 2-3 ou 4e année de
médecine ou provenant d'autres filières
de santé qui se sont portés volontaires
pour animer bénévolement ses ateliers
pendant une heure et demie ils endossent
le rôle des praticiens là normalement il
y a un petit liquide jaune comme du
sirop
allez on le mélange hop et on nettoie
comme ça c'est pour enlever toutes les
petites bactéries alors à ce stand du
coup on est au bloc opératoire donc pour
nous ce qui est important qu'ils
comprennent c'est les règles de
stérilité donc on leur fait porter une
charlotte pour les cheveux et une sur
blouse on parle de l'ophtalmologue qui
est le médecin qui des yeux et on leur
fait voir plein de plaquettes plein de
petits exercices par exemple des
planches sur lesquelles on va évaluer
l'état des yeux de nounours du coup une
pédagogie qui a séduit les professeurs
car en plus de soigner les appréhensions
l'exercice permet aussi de faire de la
prévention et de la sensibilisation à la
santé dès le plus jeune âge si votre
bobo il est sale qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire en premier
on le nettoie alors on trouvait ça
important que là en présence de médecins
en fait au futur médecin et les enfants
puissent en fait découvrir le métier des
médecins qui ont bien rempli leur
mission car à la fin de la journée tous
les patients sont rentrés guéris